So what actually goes into
getting images from the Internet
onto the screen in your app?
Well, there's a networking part
to actually download the images,
can't do that on the main thread so
we'll have to use a background thread.
You probably want to cache
the images locally to prevent
unnecessary repeated downloading.
Oh, and down sampling and decoding.
It doesn't make sense to load giant
images, just to display tiny icons.
Well and we have icons on our list, so
probably want some behavior to ensure
that we can still scroll
our list nice and smoothly.
A whole bunch of images are loaded or
cancel requests for images that are no
longer visible due to life cycle changes
such as our activity being paused.
Then it add the image to the screen
at least we have image view there.
Oh, and
we have our notification as well.
There we probably do need to get the
whole image as we build the notification
so maybe a synchronous API for
this case.
Anyone else thinking this
is a bit complicated?
You can't just cut out any of these
steps if we want to go to experience.
But none of the logic here is
unique to sunshine, right?
Plenty of other ops have gone
through the same flow and
tackle these same steps.
When you see these types of
reusable pieces of code it's
a great time to consider
using a library.